remember how long the water temple took
you in the Legend of Zelda Ocarina of
Time now imagine trying to beat it with
your eyes closed F at right well this
blind gamer didn't just beat the water
temple but the entire game almost five
years after starting his adventure on
May 8th 2011 Terry Garrett who goes by
mega T Garrett on YouTube has completed
ocarina of time using solely to game
stereo audio by placing two speakers one
to his right and one to his left Garrett
is able to gauge which direction noise
is coming from in the game's world audio
cues from Navi were essential in
positioning and realigning his character
two points of interest and other audio
tricks like swinging links sword against
walls not only gutted him down
passageways but helped him find things
like grass vines metal doors and of
course wooden chests as you can imagine
Garrett also made his fair share of
mistakes but with the help of his
Nintendo emulators safe state feature he
was able to use trial and error to get
through some of the game's more
difficult situations
Garrett posted the final video of his
Ocarina of Time playthrough on January
2nd saying after five years of taping
with long breaks in between I finally
beat legend of zelda ocarina of time
garrett thanked his fans for all the
help and support they provided him even
after it seemed like he was going to
give up Garrett has also shown he's
quite good at guitar hero 3 legends of
rock bit.trip Runner and Oddworld new n
tasty in his video is posted to his
channel his videos are truly fascinating
so if you're interested do check some
out and for all of your gaming news go
to GameSpot calm